hey 42 here when was the last time you
took a little something to make yourself
feel better
and no i don't mean a cheeky box fits on
christmas morning to take the edge of
family time
almost all of us have taken over the
counter pain relief for a headache
at some point or other maybe an
antihistamine for those spring sniffles
or an antacids to extinguish the fire in
your belly
after a gel phrasing we take these
things
in the belief they'll help us because
well science a few hundred years ago
if you'd visited your local doctor
complaining of a migraine
you might have returned home with a
freshly drilled hole in your head
thanks to a medical technique called
trapanning
today thankfully you'll likely be told
to take a trip
to the local pharmacy to pick yourself
up some ibuprofen
but while scanning the shells for your
doctor recommended medicine
tucked away next to the paracetamol and
erectile dysfunction treatment
you know things that actually work
according to my friend
obviously you'll find a cluster of
little bottles
labeled with words like natural and
remedy
look even closer and you'll notice
another word on these
seemingly reputable bottles homeopathy
with your ibuprofen in one hand and a
homeopathic remedy in the other
you might well assume eva would do a
good job of dispelling that pesky
migraine
after all it's the 21st century and
pharmacies surely only sell treatments
that work right actually
not so much that harmless looking bottle
of pills
you bought alongside the ibuprofen is
more akin to drilling
a hole in your head than it is to any
modern medicine
think of homeopathy and images of sacred
herbs minerals and essential oils might
come to mind
with common side effects including
incessant whale songs
incense and the total absence of
rational thought
but this really couldn't be any further
from the truth
well apart from the bit about whale
songs and gullibility
the number one ingredient in homeopathic
remedies
water so why you might ask
am i comparing water to someone drilling
a hole in your head
to answer this question i need to take
you back to 1796
when homeopathy was invented back then
medical care was for want of a better
word
[ __ ] as a result getting ill was often a
death sentence
to be fair doctors in those days had
little prior knowledge to go on
and had to make do with a trial and
error approach most of the time
with trial basically involving fiddling
around a bit with your insides
and hoping for the best and error
involving you being dead an infamous
example of just
how much physicians of the time got it
wrong was the procedure of bloodletting
bloodletting if you're not already aware
is the
act of draining a patient's blood either
by placing
leeches on their skin or simply by
taking a knife
and stubbing them a bit doctors used
bloodletting on george washington whilst
he lay on his deathbed
and yes i did say deathbed because
shockingly draining almost four liters
of blood
had little to no effect on the throat
infection that had been bothering him
it did very effectively kill him though
now you don't need six years at med
school
and a stethoscope to figure out that
letting someone's blood
drain away as if you were emptying a big
fleshy bath
isn't much of an idea bleeding to death
and the high risk of infection aside the
chances of bloodletting actually
curing you of your ailment was
practically non-existent
so surely doctors only prescribed this
lethal procedure
as a last resort unfortunately not
bloodlessing was all the rage back then
representing the go-to
treatment for pretty much anything it
was the 18th to 19th century version
of putting a wet blue paper towel on it
at school
which as far as i can remember actually
did cure everything
pneumonia bloodletting smallpox
bloodletting acne bloodletting
nosebleed bloodletting for you
and if by some miracle bloodletting
didn't cure you or kill you of course
there were plenty of other cutting-edge
treatments out there for you to try
these included forced vomiting induced
sweating
and yes you've guessed it drilling a
hole
in your head samuel hahnemann a german
physician at the time
was quite understandably dissatisfied
with the state of his profession
feeling the medical treatments he had
been taught
sometimes did the patient more harm than
good something i'm inclined to agree
with him about
though that is admittedly the only
overlap in our
worldview venn diagrams hanuman believed
in a doctrine called similar similar bus
code
or like cures like
the basic principle was this taking
something which causes the same symptoms
you're trying to treat
will cure you of your ailment this all
sounds
very well and good albeit devoid of any
actual scientific reasoning
until you realize most illnesses cause
pretty horrible symptoms which in turn
leads to some shall we say eyebrow
raising homeopathic elixirs
for example for someone suffering from
burning
watery eyes under runny nose due to hay
fever
your homeopathic prescription would be
made from onion
because as anyone who's ever suffered
the wrath of an onion whilst preparing
dinner will tell you
that shit's potent it's hard to believe
rubbing raw onion in your eyes would
cure you of hay fever
though i can see it might take your mind
off it for a bit whilst you focus on the
inevitable excruciating pain
but suffering is kind of part of the
homeopathic deal
the word homeopathy actually comes from
the greek
omios meaning similar
and pathos meaning suffering
before you go rubbing raw onion in your
eyes the next time the pollen count is
high
even hanuman started to realize his
treatments were causing
unpleasant reactions sometimes even
dangerous ones
yeah no [ __ ] examples include
ingesting a potentially lethal
vomit-inducing
poison as a treatment for seasickness
that one didn't go down too well quite
literally
begrudgingly hanuman instructed that his
preparations be given
at the lowest possible dose which helped
to reduce
unwanted side effects in simple terms
he transformed his concoctions from
being
dangerous and useless to just plain
useless
but hanuman didn't see it that way in
like cures like he'd found himself a
catchy tagline
and by god he was going to make it work
it just so happened that around this
time he had a magical epiphany
amazingly and conveniently
he discovered that the more his active
ingredients were diluted
in either alcohol or water the better
the patient responded to them
yeah that must have been it nothing to
do with the fact that
doing nothing turned out to be a much
better treatment than
doing harm surprisingly rashes clear up
on their own when you're not smothering
them in
extract of poison ivy that's a real
homeopathic treatment by the way
hanuman took this heavily flawed logic
and ran with it pushing the limits of
dilution to the extreme safe in the
knowledge that the weaker he made his
remedies
the more potent they became the fruit of
all this watered-down labor was the
creation of something called
the sentesama scale or as it's more
commonly referred to
the c scale let's start with the
strongest
which in haneman's topsy-turvy land
naturally means
the weakest strength on the c scale
1c to make this dilution your friendly
neighborhood homeopath
simply takes one drop of his active
ingredient
and mixes it with 100 drops
of water any rational person can see
that diluting a substance in this way
could only serve to make it
weaker but hannemann had a trick up his
sleeve
succussion it may sound like a
neanderthal attempting to pronounce
succession
but it was actually just a fancy word
for vigorously shaking your newly
diluted substance
either by hitting the bottle repeatedly
against the palm of your hand
or bashing it on a leather-bound book
yes that actually was one of the rules
hanuman believed this process of
diluting and
succussing shaking to you and me
a mixture resulted in the release of a
spirit-like power within the medicine
because
according to him water
has memory coincidentally that's a
belief shared by olaf from frozen
this liquid would then be sprayed onto
little white round sugar pills
to make for easier consumption let's
take things up
or should that be down a notch by moving
on to the next number on the c
scale 2c to make
a 2c dilution all you have to do is take
a single drop
from your newly succust bottle of 1c
solution
and add that to 100 drops of water
oh and batch it against a bug obviously
you can't expect it to cure you if you
don't bash it against the book
now the original active ingredient has
been watered down
to one part in ten thousand
want free c sure just take a drop from
the two sea bottle
and add it to another hundred drops of
water being careful to give it a good
book bashing when you're done
or your efforts will be [ __ ] useless
you've now diluted it to one part
in one million i think we're getting the
hang of this
so let's get a little frisky and fast
forward to sexy
at this strength your active ingredient
makes up
one part in a trillion of your solution
that's the equivalent of one drop in 20
swimming pools
at 12 c it's reduced to
one part in a septillion that's the same
as
one drop in the atlantic ocean
repeat this long-winded and undeniably
ridiculous process
30 times and you'll end up at hanuman's
recommended strength
30c that's one part
in a novum decilion for those of you
who've never heard of that number before
that's a one with 60 zeros after it
to put that into perspective it's about
how many atoms there are
in the sun put one drop of your active
ingredient
in all of the oceans on earth and your
solution would be
far far more concentrated than a 30
c homeopathic dilution in fact
you would need to give 2 billion doses
per second
to 6 billion people for 4 billion years
to deliver a single molecule of the
original material
to a single patient put simply
at that strength there is no active
ingredient
your fancy homeopathic solution is just
water nothing else but according to
hanuman
that makes it more potent than ever
homeopaths don't even bother arguing
that there's any remaining active
ingredient left in their treatments
even they admit their solutions are just
water
it's about the memory of the water
remember
but if we humoured that somewhat iffy
hypothesis for just a second
it raises rather a lot of questions if
water really does have
memory then surely every time i help
myself to a
cold refreshing glass of high quality
h2o
my body is being bombarded by every
single thing that water
has come into contact with millions of
animals
humans rivers lakes muddy puddles
sewers toilets donald trump's chest hair
and the bed sheets of the ritz-carlton
hotel
scientists have even theorised that
every time you drink a glass of water
there are pretty good odds at least one
molecule
has passed through the bladder of oliver
cromwell
homeopathy then to the modern ear sounds
like a load of
heavily heavily diluted [ __ ]
which i regret to inform you is also a
genuine homeopathic remedy
but in the 18th century it was either
that
or grabbed the leeches and without the
scientific knowledge we have now
who can really blame them i'd rather
drink a nice glass of water
than have someone drill a hole in my
head any day of the week
this was a time when scientists believed
there were tiny little people
living inside your sperm and
that making a baby essentially involved
unleashing an army of minuscule manned
submarines on a mission to hunt down the
egg
we've moved on since then thankfully
because that is
deeply disturbing and modern medicine
now relies on a
little thing called evidence so
surely homeopathy has fallen by the
wayside
no longer required in our enlightened
age
unfortunately not according to the
homeopathic research institute
so take this with a dilution of salt
over 200
million people worldwide use homeopathy
on a regular basis that's more than the
population of russia
many celebrities swear by homeopathic
remedies
including david beckham cindy crawford
usain bolt and emma watson it's a name
but a few
the british royal family are also
massive fans of this magical water
queen elizabeth ii is said to never
travel anywhere
without her first aid homeopathic remedy
kit
with all these impressive endorsements
it's not surprising to hear
the global market value for homeopathy
in 2017
was approximately 5.39
billion us dollars so what's happening
surely these people should know better
yeah
maybe not bex but the rest of them or
do they know something we don't does
homeopathy
actually work and all this time we could
have been experiencing its healing
powers ourselves
no definitely absolutely 100
no numerous studies on double-blind
tests
have investigated homeopathy's healing
properties and pretty much all of them
have come to the same conclusion
homeopathy is nothing
more than a placebo if you want to learn
the ins and outs of the placebo effect
you can check out my video on the
subject
i'll add a link in the description but
in a nutshell
it's your mind playing tricks on you now
those tricks
can in themselves be pretty powerful
but that doesn't change the fact that
they're nothing more
than mind-based smoke and mirrors
which is why several prominent
international bodies
the british medical association amongst
them have recommended the withdrawal of
government funding for homeopathy
and yes i did say government funding
it turns out australia the united
kingdom
switzerland france and no doubt many
more countries
have been dipping into the public purse
to fund these diluted water pellets
in 2016 it was estimated the nhs
that's britain's national health service
spent an
eye-watering 5 million pounds
on homeopathic treatments after
countless campaigns to have homeopathy
removed from its list of treatments
in 2017 the nhs formally requested
that homeopathic remedies be added to
the blacklist of forbidden prescription
items
which sounds like a textbook for a
defense against a dark arts class at
hogwarts
and like the dark hearts it also makes
homeopathy
sound kind of dangerous doesn't it
but surely a placebo effect can't be
doing any harm
can it well it turns out that homeopathy
might be doing more harm than good after
all
in 2019 the fda released a statement
saying that homeopathic products have
the potential to cause significant
and even permanent harm but hang on
there a second 42
you've just spent this whole video
trying to tell me there's nothing to
these pills
now you're expecting me to believe
they're dangerous well
yes but let me explain homeopathic
remedies are made from
literally anything from plants as
innocent as a daisy
to the highly toxic belladonna
animal and human bodily fluids make the
cut
most of the time diseased as do minerals
from
salt to mercury and a host of deadly
bacteria
if the dilution process is done
correctly
there shouldn't be a single molecule of
these substances
present in the final remedy
but when mixed incorrectly the effects
can be
devastating take a look at this bottle
of
hyland's teething tablets it seems
innocent enough
i'm sure you'll agree it claims to be
natural and to have no side effects
if you had a screaming baby at home
chewing on everything in sight
these might seem like a safe option to
help soothe your child's teething pains
plenty of people agreed in 2004
it was the second most popular teething
product in the us
so why then in 2010
did the fda raise concerns over these
little
harmless pills oh just because
laboratory results showed they contained
inconsistent and sometimes excessive
amounts
of belladonna what's bellatonna only one
of the most toxic plants we've
ever discovered also known as deadly
nightshade belladonna
it's so poisonous that eating just a
small quantity of its leaves or berries
can kill you and touching its leaves can
leave you with a serious
rash give some to a baby and teething
would be the least of their worries the
fda
claims it received 400 reports
of adverse reactions to hyland's
teething tablets
with the most prevalent side effect
being seizures
it's also estimated that 10 children
lost their lives
due to this unregulated homeopathic
medicine
so did highlands stop selling it
well yes and no
they eventually discontinued the
belladonna containing
formula after a lengthy tug of war with
the fda
with a spokeswoman for highlands
insisting the teething
formula was safe and that they are a top
selling product and the consumer
favorite
they also expressed regret that 24 staff
members lost their jobs
as a result of the product's withdrawal
i see their ethics have been diluted too
6c at least today they sell a belladonna
free
oral pain relief homeopathic remedy
its active ingredient arnica montana
also called wolfsbane a herb
known for causing severe gastroenteritis
internal bleeding of the digestive tract
and
death brilliant but seriously how can
this happen
aren't there meant to be health and
safety standards for the products we
consume
you'd think so but in the us under
current policy
the fda does not evaluate homeopathic
treatments for safety
or effectiveness and in the uk
there's no legal regulation of
homeopathic practitioners
whatsoever you don't need any
qualifications
or any experience which means i could
literally start diluting any bloody
substances in water
and sell them as miracle cures for a
pretty penny
or whilst calling myself a certified
homeopath
and it would be completely legal roll up
roll up come get your mustache
water strength 42c
but you're not just putting your life on
the line with what you do
take when you opt for a homeopathic
remedy
it's what you don't take that might
cause you the most harm
whether it's juice cleanse fanatics
mystical healers or gwyneth paltrow and
her magical goop stickers
when it comes to health everyone has an
opinion on
what you should and shouldn't do and
most of the time
indulging in a bit of alternative
medicine won't do you any harm
it probably won't do you any good either
but that's okay
but when you hear stories of how pam
next door beat breast cancer by carrying
a crystal in her bra every day
that's when things start to go a bit
wrong because
sure she may have genuinely carried a
coloured rock in her underwear for a
year
but when she gets the all clear from the
doctor it won't be
the grueling chemo that gets to credit
no it was the magical crystal nestled in
her tits that did it
and it's stories like this that cause an
undercurrent of suspicion regarding
modern medicine why follow through with
a treatment full of chemicals and
side effects when you can enlist the
power of mother earth
and cure yourself naturally this
unfortunately was the tragic basis
of the tale of seven-year-old francesco
from the italian town of cagley
when diagnosed with a common ear
infection
francesco's parents decided against
giving their son antibiotics
as his doctors recommended instead they
consulted their local homeopath
who prescribed a homeopathic remedy
which was to magically cure him
thanks to the infallible memory of water
three days later
francesca was dead the young boy had
fallen into a coma
after the infection in his ear spread to
his brain
and he died of encephalitis had he been
taken to a hospital
and been given modern medicines he might
still be alive today
so the next time you're choosing between
that packet of ibuprofen
and some magical sugar pills just
remember
you're choosing between science and
pseudoscience
the future and the past
evidence and faith and perhaps
even life and death
thanks for watching what's that i hear
you say
you want to experience my new book stick
a flag in it
but you can't be asked to read i hear
you
that's why you can now get the audio
book release of sticker flag in it
over on audible you'll find the link in
the description below
thank you